good morning my name is Faizal Whelpley
I work with the net math program at the
University of Illinois
this talk title automated test
generation is based off of a Mathematica
package Mathematica application that I
started working on two years ago quick
history about net math it started off as
calculus and Mathematica professors at U
of I oh hi O state got together under
NSF grant to develop Mathematica based
calculus reform project the students
will work on computers with Mathematica
notebook text input graphics all
available to them they get to modify
code run code and use that as part of
their homework assignments the nat math
program started with approaching this
idea to high schoolers ruler Houska High
School in Illinois I think the name net
math actually took on 1996 but the C's
for it were planted before that so I'm
actually being modest when I say that
math is the longest-running and most
successful online mathematics program in
the world we have several different
modes of operation you can look us up
online netmask
Illinois edu self-paced rolling
enrollment is something that you don't
get quite a lot of students can sign on
and any time they get 16 weeks to
complete the program but we also do
still with partner high school programs
and for UIUC students only we take on
summer students so that's enough history
and there's gonna be a lot of live demo
here the actual slides doesn't contain
all that much interesting stuff the
problem I was presented was that we are
writing paper exams on a regular basis
we handcrafting them if you ever teach
the class
I assume you wrote paper exams of course
in 2016 you might be wondering why am I
still writing it for exams well that's a
long history established reasons why we
still use paper exams we try to
de-emphasize them our homework
assignments are worth more than our
exams
scores but they still worth something
like 40% of the grade come from exams so
we handcraft this exams put them in from
the students proctored they send us back
the exams we grade them and they get
responses feedback on that exam what we
would like to do is automate the process
and this this idea of automation is it's
very interesting because what we what we
started designing was a database because
we know what kind of questions we want
to ask so we started with a database
where we started populating questions
and answers and the database is
parametrized so some certain certain
elements of the question can be
generated on the fly so let's take a
look at one of these databases here
so this is an example database for our
math 241 course which is a multivariate
vector calculus course this is all
notebook Mathematica notebook with
interface elements to let the author of
these questions to create questions and
specify an answer for this question and
set metadata they can set metadata
things like difficulty level of this
question what was score like how to
weight the score the type of the
question because we do ask a lot of
conceptual questions in addition to
computational questions and some
keywords these keywords can be chosen
from the library we sort of have made up
this index of keywords that you can pull
from so you don't have to write it from
scratch you can still do it but there's
a nice library to choose from to sort of
keep your keywords uniform in a sense
and it's been working out quite nicely
like this is a this is an actual test
Bank with a lot of questions in there
and these green blob that you see are
actually parametrizations so here we can
actually take a look at one of these if
I go to edit this it just comes up in a
dialogue box that allows me to specify a
label for this what code I want a
description for this piece of code and I
can preview this code as I'm writing
this editing this the input line here is
dimmed out which means it's not gonna
show up on the exam and you can show
that to you by clicking this preview
button which would generate the exam
generate the question as you would
preview it somewhere
my previous better than the black screen
by the way I'm going to get us off of
this and it preview here so that's how a
preview will look like so that's one
preview and I I said this was
parametrize so let's see what happens if
I generate another preview oh I get the
same question but the parametrized
elements which get generated every time
I could preview shows up differently in
the exam so same question different
element parametric's so it gives me a
lot of control as an author of the exam
if I know what kind of questions I'm
going to be asking I can even write one
exam and cater to you know multiple
students in the same class but they all
get their own different numbers but it's
it's it's a lot of work because I I have
to author this question there's this
nothing automatic about that part this
is my database of questions actually
this is an MF database of questions so
don't use this one and we have tons and
tons of this we through a lot of
teaching assistants th effort into
creating these these questions and they
they did a lot of lot of work generating
ideas for questions what kind of things
should be parametrized or what kind of
things should not be parametrized
especially when you're asking conceptual
questions it's really hard sometimes to
come by a parameterization which element
should be parametrized so we got this
database now questions and answers
what's the next step the next step
turned out that we want to get out of
full screen
was the template so template is where I
want to specify the layout of the
questions how I want the paper exam or
how I want to pull my questions from
this database to slot into my paper
exams so a template file will look like
this again another method Mathematica
notebook that I open up and set and and
start inserting these this tells this
blobs and I can use those keywords
metadata and keywords in other metadata
to sort of specify what type of
questions should appear in question one
what type of question should appear in
question two so this keyword says I need
a vector question in question one or a
line school and the lines question in
question two so by using these keywords
and all this other metadata there's a
build process that I'm gonna run in a
second that will dive into my database
of questions and try to fill this
template in with an actual exam and
that's what this button is for so once I
have a template I hit build an exam I
get spinny spinny spinny and boom
there's an exam and it comes with the
solution key all the parameterization
filled in and anything that needs to be
random is random anything needs to be
generated during runtime is generated so
I now I can save this for myself as the
greater is the instructor whoever's
creating the exam so I can see a set of
questions and answers this is also
printable so I can take this in print it
as PDF because you know we're doing this
on paper so now we have a paper form of
our solution and answer key how does
that look in in the exam view
[Music]
there's no way so I also have a button
here to flip this between how the
solution answered solution key looks to
how the actual exam looks so this is how
this is what you know eventually I put
in furnace today not quite a ready
product yet does anybody see a problem
with this I can I can print this out by
the way so I can put this in PDF and you
put this in front of students sorry it's
too bright that's a difficult problem to
solve how much space the I don't know if
you notice there is a line for spaces
how much big but when you're writing
questions you have no idea how much
space you want to give and even if you
know exactly how much space you want to
give them he's gonna mess up your line
breaking when you print the sub to paper
so what I did was to is this probably a
terrible idea but what I did was to work
with the cell size option in Mathematica
that allows you to do this and if you
can see this oh no I can't demo this one
sorry because it's broken
I had a I had an interface where you can
drag your your enlarged yourself and the
the the easy way to do it would just be
to add your white spaces here so that
when when the students get it they have
enough white space and you can see the
line break there so if I don't have
enough space there's this bar here that
tells me he's got a line break at the
end of question two which is maybe what
I want I can also insert page breaks
manually so that I know it's not going
to break in between a question but
that's a lot of manual effort that's
going to go in into actually finalizing
this exam and putting it in front of
student but that's the that's the state
of the automated test generator at the
moment so the next now that now that we
have this product we've done this once
we generated about 20 or so exams for
the summer and the process still needs
to be smooth down there there was some
flaws here and there but it survived
first round
[Music]
I do and I kind of have it I just don't
know if where it is sitting or where it
should be sitting that is appropriate
right now is sitting as part of the
database which is far removed from from
the exam and is one step removed from
getting the exam but even if I if even
if I add this parameterization I don't
think the final product is going to be
completely manual free you're still
going to have to have a human being sort
of look through it make sure yeah I
wanted ten spaces that's what I said but
I'm looking at right now I don't want
ten straight so you gotta have to have
that manual interaction with this
because it is it is gonna you know end
up on the paper so it even if I had that
option is not going to be completely
automated still am I worried yes
[Music]
what you won somebody's made these
things right what it was about em I know
mr. metadata here which says problem two
is testing right so that so that after
the fact we just get one of these
documents or some fun little tin can we
figure out what was it that was being
tested here at what frequency because
suppose you're making the next test
there's no well okay to answer your
first question we teach I believe nine
courses and very very number of student
enrollments in highest we have like a
hundred 150 students and the lowest is
like twenty students so let's say a
collection of 250 students in a semester
that we teach but spread over ten nine
ten courses so yes we went to generate
the first midterm exam final exam for
all these courses and we want to do that
again process that process again next
year so none of this is gonna it's gonna
be repeated use for these so that's that
was the use case as for tying this back
there's no reporting sense if that's
what you're looking for and you can
match this question coming from the
template that exam was produced by
clicking the build exam button on this
template so you do have a one to one
correspondence and you can locate this
this question back in the database so
you know where in the database this
question got pulled from so you have
another cross-check between why the this
set of criteria pull in that question so
I have vectors and lesson to us the key
words here and this one has vectors
listen to it as a keyword the build the
algorithm for picking this can be
refined I was wondering we gonna be one
of my next steps how these things are
matched right now there there's there's
some sort of algorithmic ranking but
it's very very simplistic there's
nothing preventing me from working on
that more to make that better but also
can I think we can't collect data like
that and make a report of alright how
many times you know this question was
reused or how many times questions of
that type got used in an exam I never
really thought about that but certainly
can be done
that's a great question because I don't
have to I don't write these questions
but yes a lot of tears the head had run
into the problem and it takes a lot of
mental power to to decide how you want
to constrain your parametrizations so
you don't run into square root of 22 in
your exams but that's a that's the
question that we have to address at the
time of writing the questions this is
why we I built in all this preview stuff
so that you can click on this multiple
time get different variations of this
and make sure you know your answers key
is something that can be solved by hand
because this is paper exam they need to
be able to solve this by hand
[Music]
so how many people still give paper
exams about as much as I expected how
many people like to not give them paper
exams there couple I don't I feel like
we are in a day and age that we should
stop paper exams I know that's easier
said than done I've been working with
University for one year I I'm slowly
getting the hint but I don't know paper
exempt seems seems like a legacy carry
over oh thank you all right thank you
everybody
[Applause]